[Musique]
et
au début du mois d'octobre 1944
l'allemagne menaçaient de tout côté
était dans une situation critique que
même la très efficace propagande nazi ne
pouvait plus masquée
au début de la guerre après que les
panzers nazis et déferlé sur la pologne
hitler semblait invincible au fil des
mois le führer fini par le croire
considérant qu'il s'agissait d'un état
de fait appelée à se prolonger
pourtant depuis que les américains
étaient entrés en guerre aux côtés des
alliés après l'attaqué japonaise contre
la flotte américaine à pearl harbor en
décembre 1941 hitler et les forces de l'
axe subissait une pression soutenue en
de nombreux points du globe
en afrique du nord fin 1942 les
allemands avaient été battus lors de la
seconde bataille d'elle à la marine
lorsque le général montgomery et la
viiie armée britannique avait affronté
le renard du désert le général erwin
rommel et l'avait fait plier la
détermination de montgomery était aussi
forte que celle affichée par les
allemands il l'avait démontré de façon
spectaculaire à la veille de la bataille
en détruisant tous les plans prévus pour
une éventuelle de retraite prévenant ses
officiers si nous sommes attaqués
il n'y aura pas de retraite si nous ne
pouvons pas tenir ici vivent alors nous
resterons ici morts
[Musique]
c'est cet esprit combatif nouveau
affiché par les alliés en europe ou dans
le pacifique qui changeait la donne
[Musique]
en attaquant l'armée rouge en 1941
hitler s'étaient retrouvés impliqués
dans plus de combats qu'ils ne l'avaient
anticipé ses plans pour vaincre les
soviétiques rapidement et définitivement
au cours des mois d'été
c'est à dire avant l'arrivée du terrible
hiver russes furent mises à mal les
forces d'invasion allemandes eurent à
affronter une résistance plus rude que
prévu
en février 1943 la sixième armée
allemande avaient été anéanties lors de
la bataille de stalingrad et au cours de
la bataille de koursk un peu plus tard
pour la première fois la tactique du
blitzkrieg et choix
[Musique]
en europe de l'ouest les succès des
alliés en afrique du nord
le débarquement en sicile et l'attaquent
de l'italie menaçait les plans
méditerranéen du troisième reich
en allemagne la santé dit l'air se
dégrade est les historiens pensent qu'il
souffrait des premiers symptômes de la
maladie de parkinson les apparitions
publiques du führer était de plus en
plus rares pourtant hitler et ses alliés
de lax était sur le point d'affronter la
plus grande menace envisageable celle de
la force d'invasion alliés rassemblés
sur la côte sud de l'angleterre prête à
libérer la france et a entamé l'avancée
vers berlin
[Musique]
le jour j le 6 juin 1944 fut un épisode
capital en cas d'échec l'issue de la
seconde guerre mondiale aurait sûrement
été différente
sous le commandement suprême du général
eisenhower les alliés débarquèrent sur
les plages de normandie prenant ainsi un
avantage décisif sur les allemands qui
s'attendaient à ce que la taxe sur
vienne vers calais
[Musique]
les américains chargés de s'emparer de
la côte au sud de cherbourg débarquèrent
sur les plages baptisé hutin et omar les
britanniques et les canadiens mire pied
à terre à gold juno et sword autre plage
à proximité de caen à la fin du premier
jour
cent trente mille hommes avaient
débarqué en un mois plus d'un million de
soldats combattait en france
[Musique]
les à l'iran contraire de nombreuses
poches de résistance en dépit du succès
du débarquement
hitler n'allait pas abandonner sans
combattre durant l'été 1944
les conditions météorologiques sur
déplorable les ali réalisèrent que la
route qui les attendait était semée
d'embûches et que de durs combats les
attendait
[Musique]
à l'est les russes déclenchent est une
opération de grande envergure
nom de code bague ration
[Musique]
l'objectif de bagues ration était de
repousser en pologne
or de ce qui est aujourd'hui la
république de biélorussie toutes les
armées allemandes
les historiens ont décrit cette
opération comme l'une des plus
sanglantes de l'histoire
mais plus important pour les alliés elle
fut la plus calamiteuse défaite de
toutes les forces armées allemandes
durant la seconde guerre mondiale
[Musique]
l'armée rouge avant ça rapidement et
atténue la pologne décimant les unités
allemandes les unes après les autres
causant des pertes qui se sont élevés à
plus de 670 mille hommes les forces
d'hitler est tiré de l'ouest à l'est en
raison du débarquement et de cette
opération ne pouvait espérer aucun
renfort
les lourdes pertes subies à l'est à la
suite de l'opération bague ration
s'ajoutant à celle subie à l'ouest
pendant le jour j et les mois qui
suivirent frappé durement le moral de la
population allemande
hitler devaient rapidement reprendre
l'initiative afin de prouver qu'il
menait toujours le jeu il dévoila alors
son arme secrète le v1 lever 1 avait été
conçu dès le début de la guerre mais ce
n'est qu'à cette date qui claire décida
de se servir de ce cui 100 missiles
[Musique]
le grand avantage du v1 était qu'aucun
pilote n'était nécessaire
une fois lancée grâce à une technologie
avancée pour l'époque il se dirigeait
vers sa cible
et quand il atteignait il explosait son
efficacité était terrible surnommé buzz
bombe en raison du son particulier du
réacteur
on savait qu'il était sur le point
d'exploser car lorsque le buzz
s'arrêtait après un court silence d'une
quinzaine de secondes
la charge d'une tonne explosé
[Musique]
hitler concentra cv 1 sur londres où il
causèrent d'importants dommages
[Musique]
cette menace permanente entraînant
l'évacuation immédiate de tous les
enfants loin de londres les britanniques
furent prompt à contrer ces attaques sur
les 2452 v1 lancé la rff parvint en
abattre environ un tiers
[Musique]
très intelligemment un véritable black
out de la presse britannique empêcha les
allemands de se faire une idée du
résultat de ces attaques
bien que dévastatrice l'armé secrète
d'hitler arrivé trop tard pour lui
permettre de gagner la guerre
[Musique]
en france un début de pénurie de
carburant posait un problème aux alliés
le manque de port en eau profonde
compliqué l'acheminement du
ravitaillement aux normes en gomery
désormais maréchal préparaient une
offensive sur l'allemagne depuis la
belgique
[Musique]
eisenhower lui demanda de changer
d'option et de s'emparer du port
d'anvers grand port opérationnel ce qui
améliorerait la situation globale des
alliés montgomery adoré par ses hommes
avaient en revanche la réputation d'être
difficile à commander il continua selon
ses propres plans prétextant que la
stratégie d'eisenhower exigé des
renforts
ce qui à ce moment là n'était pas
envisageable
ayant beaucoup progresser vers le rhin
grâce à des actions courtes et
concentrées montgomery mis sur pied son
opération market garden l'objectif les
ponts sur le rhin qui ouvrait la voie
sur berlin dont il voulait s'emparer
intact le mot market faisait référence à
l' offensive aéroportée massive et le
mot garden aux troupes au sol pour que
l'opération réussisse ses deux forces
devaient travailler conjointement mais
les difficultés s'accumulent air en
raison de problèmes de planification les
précédentes opérations de cette ampleur
avait été préparé pendant des mois et
avait fait l'objet de répétitions alors
que la préparation de market garden
avait été achevé en une semaine sans
répétition ni entraînement tactique
plusieurs commandants étaient inquiets
compte tenu du caractère d'improvisation
de cette opération
mais mon tit re est adroit dans ses
bottes lorsqu'on lui montra des preuves
photographiques de concentration de
chars très proche de certaines zones
d'atterrissage
il prétendit qu'ils étaient hors service
[Musique]
l'opération market garden et choix
essentiellement en raison du problème de
carburant les alliés ne disposons pas
d'un port important
les allemands eurent assez de temps pour
acheminer leurs renforts et consolider
leur position va me l'homme périr avant
que montgomerie ne soit forcé de reculer
un temps précieux avait été perdue par
sa faute il était désormais urgent
d'apporter une solution aux problèmes du
carburant car sans un approvisionnement
régulier la route des alliés vers berlin
serait particulièrement compliqué comme
eisenhower l'avait voulu dans un premier
temps le port belge d'anvers fut la
cible suivante
la bataille sur l'escaut fut dur
elle avait commencé le 2 octobre le long
de l'escaut et malgré une résistance
acharnée des allemands pour défendre le
port
il fut finalement pris et immédiatement
remise en service pour les navires
alliés
[Musique]
la réouverture du port d'anvers au nord
ainsi que la prise de l'important port
de marseille au sud de la france mis un
terme définitif aux problèmes de pénurie
de carburant qui menaçaient les alliés
le début du mois d'octobre vie la fin du
soulèvement de varsovie faits
historiques très controversé encore
aujourd'hui les nationalistes polonais
combattaient pour arracher leur capital
des mains allemandes
ce soulèvement aurait dû être le point
fort de l'opération tempête mené par
l'armée intérieure polonaise avec pour
objectif de libérer la pologne du
nazisme
avant que les soviétiques n'en prenne le
contrôle il s'est avéré rapidement que
varsovie est être bien défendu pour que
les polonais puisse en venir à bout
seul c'était l'opportunité parfaite
offerte aux russes de remettre les
compteurs à zéro après bague ration
l'armée rouge se trouvait à moins de 10
km de la ville polonaise en flammes
lorsqu'elle reçut l'ordre de stopper
brutalement les soviétiques observèrent
les polonais se battre pendant soixante
quatre jours sanglants avant qu ils ne
lèvent le drapeau blanc de la reddition
au coeur de la controverse se trouve le
prétexte évoqué par le leader soviétique
joseph staline pour ne pas venir en aide
à l'armée intérieure polonaise
certains historiens estiment que staline
avait demandé à son armée de stopper
afin que les polonais soient massacrés
et ne soit plus en mesure de s'opposer
au régime soviétique
après la guerre l'explication officielle
russe argué d'une pénurie de carburants
et de l'épuisement des troupes qui
n'aurait pas été en état d'affronter les
allemands
indéniablement les soviétiques avaient
été très actif pendant le mois d'octobre
dès le 6 il avait débuté une offensive
dans l'est de la hongrie
si les russes parvenait à s'emparer de
cette zone
la porte du sud de l'allemagne l'heure
serait ouverte
la violente attaque débuta par une
action du deuxième front ukrainien qui
déferla sur la troisième armée ambroise
mais l'offensive dû ralentir car les
allemands avaient bâti une ligne de
défense solide les soviétiques
traitèrent les civils en gros un sans
considération commettant des atrocités
qui rendirent les troupes hongroises
encore plus déterminés bien que
largement inférieurs en nombre même
associé aux allemands la bataille de
debrecen se termina pour ses troupes
avec les honneurs
[Musique]
mais l' axe ne pouvait contenir les
russes très longtemps le 4 novembre
l'armée rouge s'emparait de la capitale
hongroise budapest
[Musique]
athènes ne fut également libéré en
octobre la grèce avait été envahie par
les italiens en 1940 mais ceux ci furent
contenu jusqu'à ce kit l'air à
contre-coeur envoie ses hommes en 1941
et jusqu'en 1944
la grèce fut une nation occupée sous
contrôle des forces de l' axe cependant
le gouvernement grec en exil réussi à
lever une armée qui s'avéra très utile
aux alliés dans les campagnes d'afrique
du nord et en italie
en octobre 1944 les russes progressait
en roumanie en yougoslavie
les troupes allemandes qui occupaient
l'adresse se trouvait alors menacé
d'être isolé par l'avancée russe lorsque
les alliés occidentaux reprirent le
contrôle d'athènes le gouvernement grec
en exil revint une semaine plus tard le
18 octobre
[Musique]
cependant ces territoires perdus
n'étaient pas les seuls problèmes
d'hitler la paranoïa du complot et la
méfiance envers son entourage tourner à
l'obsession
ce n'était pas sans fondement car il y
avait déjà eu un certain nombre de
tentatives d'assassinât contre lui en
1944 l'opération walkyrie le 20 juillet
fut la plus proche de réussir
l'attentât fut commis par claus von
stauffenberg un officier de l'état-major
personnel d'hitler il utilisa sa
position privilégiée dans l'entourage du
führer pour poser une bombe lors d'une
de ses réunions avec les officiers de
haut rang
von stauffenberg assista à l'énorme
explosion avant de filer vers berlin
pour l'étape suivante de l'opération
mais ils furent rapidement informé qu
hitler avait miraculeusement survécu
ce n'était plus qu'une question d'heures
avant que von stauffenberg ne soit
capturé et exécuté
la large enquête destinée à trouver tous
ceux qui étaient impliqués n'en n'était
pourtant qu'à son début
[Musique]
la brutalité avec laquelle les accusés
furent traités fut sans limite
certains très proche d'hitler était
impliqué dans le complot
[Musique]
le nom le plus surprenant à apparaître
fut certainement celui d'erwin rommel
qui avait pourtant toute la confiance
d'hitler et qui avait combattu si
courageusement pour la cause nazie en
afrique du nord
[Musique]
rommel avait été auparavant choisi pour
une nouvelle mission capitale
la défense de la côte française en
prévision d'un débarquement dans
l'éventualité se confirmait
[Musique]
non
le 6 juin jour j prix toutefois les
allemands par surprise
romel fit tout pour repousser
l'assaillant
mais comble de malchance il fut blessé
le 17 juillet une attaque aérienne
contre sa voiture entraîna son
hospitalisation pour de graves blessures
à la tête
[Musique]
pendant sa carrière militaire rebelle
avait toujours été opposé à certains
aspects du régime nazi et plus
spécialement aux traitements infligés
aux juifs lors de l' enquête après
l'attentât du 20 juillet des documents
au siège du complot les serres
soupçonnait que rom elle n'était pas
seulement un soutien mais aussi le chef
potentiel si l'assassinât et le coup
d'état réussi c'est même s'il n'existait
aucune preuve formelle que les
conspirateurs communiquer avec romel les
enquêteurs nazis se penchèrent sur le
cas de l'homme blessé par malheur alors
que rebelles était en convalescence à
l'hôpital
il évoqua ses désaccords avec certains
points du régime nazi
ce qui fut considéré comme une preuve de
sa trahison
[Musique]
martin bormann à la tête de la
chancellerie du parti nazi convaincu qu
aux rebelles était coupable voulait que
son cas soit présenté devant un tribunal
populaire
entre temps le 14 octobre 1944
romel reçu la visite de deux officiers
nazis qui lui firent une proposition
[Musique]
rommel était un héros hautement admiré
par le peuple allemand
c'est la raison pour laquelle en lui
offrit un choix les officiels
informèrent qu'il allait être présenté
devant norman et son tribunal populaire
ce qui signifiait aussi la poursuite de
sa famille il n'avait plus d'autre
option que le suicide rebelles dit adieu
à sa famille est suivi les deux
officiers qui deux heures plus tard
téléphoné à son épouse lui annonçant que
son mari était décédé
[Musique]
le peuple allemand fut informé que rom
elle était mort d'une crise cardiaque
comme promis il fut enterré avec les
honneurs militaires
hitler envoya le maréchal von rundstedt
pour le représenter romel à peine inhumé
la première grande bataille à se
dérouler sur le sol allemand se
déclencher à aix-la-chapelle la bataille
d'aix comment ça le 2 octobre
les allemands allaient défendre
farouchement la ville attaquée par les
américains comble de l'ironie en
septembre le commandant de la garnison
basée à aix constatant la faiblesse de
ses effectifs offrit sa reddition aux
américains cependant au lieu d'arriver
dans les mains des alliés sa lettre de
reddition fut remise à hitler
[Musique]
l'infortuné officiers furent
immédiatement arrêté et des renforts
allemands envoyés sur place
en dépit de leur combativité les efforts
des allemands furent vains les combats
étaient sans espoir
les américains étaient plus nombreux de
90 mille hommes en revanche les
allemands étaient sur leur propre
territoire et tenait solidement leur
ligne avant d'être balayée il infligeait
aux américains de lourdes pertes
[Musique]
la victoire finale revint aux alliés le
21 octobre
les pertes se montait à 5000 hommes pour
les deux camps et 5600 prisonniers
allemands
lourd bilan pour une issue imprévisible
le mois d'octobre fut une période riche
en affrontement aussi bien en europe que
dans le pacifique
il marqua le début de l'offensive
majeure des américains les batailles qui
s'étaient déroulés entre 1943 et 1944
avait contraint les japonais a reculé
jusqu'à la relative sécurité de leurs
bases dans les îles du sud et du centre
lui
oh
lorsque les japonais avaient pris le
contrôle des philippines en 1942 le
commandant des forces américaines pour
l'extrême orient était le général
douglas macarthur
c'est le président roosevelt lui même
qui ordonna à mcarthur de quitter les
philippines où il était basé macarthur
était réticent a quitté les philippines
car il sentait que l'armée américaine de
est au peuple philippin de rester pour
combattre il envisage à même de
démissionner pour poursuivre le combat
comme mercenaire cependant macarthur
finit par obéir aux ordres et s'envola
vers l'australie après avoir juré de
revenir libérer les philippines
le 20 octobre 1944 macarthur et son
état-major débarquèrent sur l'île de
l'été le général avait respecté sa
promesse
[Musique]
la bataille du golf de l'été une zone
maritime à l'est de l'île de l'été mis
aux prises l'us navy et la marine
impériale japonaise
elle fit rage entre le 23 et le 26
octobre
[Musique]
elle est considérée par beaucoup comme
étant la plus grande bataille navale de
la seconde guerre mondiale est peut-être
de toute l'histoire des guerres maritime
en réalité on peut la diviser en quatre
batailles majeures
l'amiral william à cela était à la tête
des forces américaines
grâce à une planification rigoureuse
combinée à une volonté déterminée il
permis aux alliés le 26 octobre de
remporter la victoire malgré la première
offensive des kamikazes jamais observée
[Musique]
les troupes basées sur l'île de la cité
était désormais à l'abri d'une attaque
navale
le sort des armes dans le pacifique
avait définitivement tourné en faveur
des états unis
en europe les alliés étaient cette fois
certains que la victoire et la fin du
règne d'hitler était à portée de main
l'armée rouge progressaient rapidement
et sans faire de quartier les américains
découvraient que combattre les allemands
sur leur propre territoire était une
entreprise périlleuse
[Musique]
une première illustration fut la
bataille de la forêt de rügen une zone
qui s'étend sur la frontière entre la
belgique et l'allemagne
le choc du débarquement passé les
allemands avaient renforcé leurs
positions et construit de nouvelles
défenses qui pour le moins allait
ralentir l'avancée des alliés
[Musique]
en pénétrant en allemagne un des
objectifs majeurs des alliés était de
nettoyer ces zones forestières des
troupes allemandes ce qui permettait de
les empêcher de renforcer leurs lignes
plus au nord entre aix et la rurh
[Musique]
l'affrontement commença le 19 septembre
il allait devenir la plus longue
bataille continue sur le sol allemand de
la seconde guerre mondiale mais aussi la
plus longue de l'histoire américaine
car les opérations en allait prendre fin
quand février 45
pour les allemands c'était une portion
de territoire stratégique qu'il fallait
tenir
essentiellement parce qu hitler
préparait une contre attaque devenu
célèbre
l'offensive des ardennes il s'agissait
en effet d'une zone de stationnement
pour les nombreuses troupes véhicules et
armements destinés à être engagés dans
cette offensive
[Musique]
les américains avaient leur propre
calendrier prévoyant la prise de
contrôle des barrages de la ruhr qui
pourrait être ouvert pour inonder toute
la zone
c'était une option éventuelle mais il
s'agissait d'empêcher les allemands de
se livrer à cette manoeuvre
le 5 octobre la 9e division d'infanterie
américaine attaque à la ville de schmidt
qui constituait un point important dans
la chaîne d'approvisionnement allemande
la bataille fut féroce les deux
belligérants devant tenir leurs
positions et ce n'est pas avant le 16
octobre que la 9e division américaine
réussit à être renforcé en seulement 11
jours
4500 soldats américains furent tués
démontrant que les allemands étaient
encore loin d'être battus malgré
l'arrivée des renforts
schmidt ne fut prise que le 3 novembre
en plus de la détermination de la
résistance allemande le terrain était
également difficile constitué d'une
forêt de conifères extrêmement dense
avec pratiquement aucune route ce qui
empêchait l'avancé des véhicules dans
quelques clairière les allemands avaient
installé leurs canons pour leur offrir
la plus grande efficacité de tir et il y
avait aussi beaucoup de champs de mines
recouvert par la neige de l'hiver 44 la
forêt dense était aussi un problème pour
les avions alliés qui ne pouvait pas
appuyer les troupes au sol
le terrain de 20 ans problème encore
plus grands lors de la deuxième phase de
la tacc car non seulement la météo était
encore pire
mais les chars étaient devenus
essentiels pour le combat le génie
américain était parvenu à tracer des
routes dans la zone des combats à coups
d'explosifs mais c'était un exercice
périlleux
[Musique]
la bataille continuait et le ton
détériora les conditions de combat
beaucoup de vies furent perdues
simplement à cause de la morsure du
froid et de la fatigue
un certain nombre de ses combattants
américains avaient déjà été impliqué
dans les débarquement en normandie et
certains qui avaient assisté au bain de
sang d'omaha beach
trois mille hommes avaient été massacrés
déclarèrent qu'en comparaison avec la
bataille de la forêt d'othe gun au mas
avait était une promenade de santé des
120 mille soldats engagés à horgen
quelque 33 mille furent tués ou mis hors
de combat
et bien que les combats se terminèrent
par une victoire alliée
elle fut coûteuse spécialement si on
considère que les pertes allemandes ne
représente r que la moitié de celle des
américains
[Musique]
oh
la prise du port d'anvers avait amélioré
notablement la situation du
ravitaillement
mais l'acheminement du carburant jusqu
aux premières lignes restait
problématique
les nazis occupaient toujours les zones
environnantes et lille 2e walgren avec
son point de vue dominant l'estuaire du
chêne tu es tu as gardé par la 15e armée
allemande
[Musique]
le maréchal montgomery donna des
instructions pour que la zone de shell
tu soit attaquée et l'opération en
faillite fut mis en place avec
l'objectif donné à la première armée
canadienne de dégager la zone de la
menace allemande sur les routes
d'approvisionnement de carburant
[Musique]
le bombardement des défenses allemandes
commença à la fin d'octobre
mais ce n'est que le 1er novembre que
les canadiens débarquèrent réellement
sur walgren
les allemands offrir une résistance
acharnée mais lentement et sûrement les
canadiens nettoyer chaque zone et la
phase finale débuta le 8 novembre
[Musique]
après des jours de durs engagement
quelque quarante mille soldats allemands
de l'île de wight graines et des
alentours seront dire aux canadiens
ils avaient atteint leur objectif
vers la fin du mois de novembre le port
d'anvers était totalement opérationnel
et les approvisionnements en carburants
ne furent plus un problème
[Musique]
peu de temps après l'assaut amphibie
alliés de walgren d'autres ports fut
repris et plus leur nombre augmentait
plus la position des alliés se trouvait
renforcée
[Musique]
le port de zeebrugge au nord-ouest de la
belgique fut également pris par les
alliés début novembre achevant ainsi la
libération totale de la belgique
[Musique]
c'était certainement une mauvaise
nouvelle pour hitler et son rêve d'un
reich millénaire mais le führer n'était
pas encore prêt à abandonner ses rêves
de domination du monde
une fois de plus il s'en prit à la
grande bretagne en lançant sur londres
sa nouvelle arme la fusée v2
[Musique]
les ingénieurs allemands avaient
travaillé pour améliorer le v1 qui avait
déjà porté des coups terribles au peuple
britannique
cependant le v1 avertissait de son
arrivée en raison de son bruit
particulier sur le v2 son silence allait
augmenter son efficacité
la vitesse et le contrôle de la
trajectoire du v2 était améliorée ce qui
le rendait impossible à être
interceptées ou même être abattus par
les canons antiaériens
[Musique]
le v2 et est le projet le plus onéreux
du troisième reich 100000 reich marks
pas refuser ce coup fini par devenir un
problème mais pas avant que hitler
persuadé qu'il s'agissait de larmes de
la victoire n'en est fait construire
6048 il y eut également un coût humain
terrible pour la production de ses armes
car elles étaient fabriqués dans des
usines dont la main d'oeuvre était
constituée par des détenus du camp de
travail de me talbot doha quelque vingt
mille travailleurs perdirent la vie
avant que la fusée v2 ne soit prête
[Musique]
la première fusée v2 pris son envol en
août 1944
mais ce n'est pas avant la mi novembre
qu'elle fut lancée vers sa cible
touchant la grande-bretagne 8 fois par
jour lorsque les tentatives pour la
descendre en plein ciel furent fait la
quantité massive darty réutiliser qui
retombait du ciel cause à plus de
dommages que la fusée elle même une
contre-offensive alternative était donc
indispensable
il était évident qu'une fois levée de
lancer il était impossible de le stopper
et les britanniques savaient que leur
seul espoir de détruire ces fusées était
de le faire avant qu'elle ne soit lancé
[Musique]
dans un premier temps la rff tenta de
bombarder les sites devaient de mobiles
mais ceux-ci s'avèrera particulièrement
coûteux au moment où conserver des
ressources valable était d'une
importance vitale le plan suivant était
de désinformer les allemands à propos de
la direction vers laquelle ils
envoyaient leurs armes
le renseignement britannique travaille à
sans cesse pour que de faux rapport
d'impact soit envoyée et ensuite ils
réussir à faire en sorte que les fusées
v2 vise des zones plus rurales et -
habiter loin de résoudre le problème ces
mesures atténuait seulement son impact
est en fait la seule contre attaque
valable était que les alliés avance vers
berlin
capturant les sites de lancement des v2
et en les repoussant hors de portée mais
cela devait prendre un peu de temps et
les v2 continuer à représenter une
menace véritable contre londres et les
zones environnantes
[Musique]
en dépit des dépenses exorbitantes du
projet v2 et l'indéniable succès des
attaques contre londres larmes miracle
d'hitler ne fuit pas la différence sur
l'issue de la guerre le moral des
londoniens rester optimiste bien que les
v2 puisse frapper à n'importe quel
moment
tandis qu'ils vaquaient à leurs affaires
quotidiennes
plus de 150 clients et employés furent
tués lors de l'explosion d'un v 2 / 1
magasins woolworths au total de 1754
victimes civiles britanniques furent
attribués au v 2 ainsi que 6500 blessés
comme arme d'intimidation et de terreur
le v2 hitler était efficace
en revanche il ne suffisait pas à
convaincre l'opinion publique allemande
que la puissance de lax était encore en
mesure de gagner la guerre
bien que détruisant cible après cible le
v2 et choix dans sa mission de
propagande
il devenait de plus en plus évident que
le troisième reich s'effondrait les
officiers les plus haut placés et
commencé à réaliser que tout espoir
était perdu mais comme un animal blessé
la machine de guerre nazie pouvait
encore infligé de sévères destruction et
de nombreux sévices
[Musique]
hitler était déterminé à poursuivre la
lutte des plans avait été échafaudé pour
le baroud d'honneur mais c'était une
tâche gigantesque pour les troupes
restantes à court de main d'oeuvre la
luftwaffe avait été pratiquement mise
hors de combat par la rff les
approvisionnements en carburants des
alliés s'étaient améliorés tandis que
ceux des allemands s'amenuisait de plus
en plus depuis que les champs
pétrolifères de roumanie avaient été
bombardées
[Musique]
hitler savait qu'il devait réagir bien
qu'ils deviennent de plus en plus
irrationnel il avait réalisé qu'une
victoire totale était impossible mais il
était persuadé être encore capable de
défendre l'allemagne à long terme
il neutralise est le front ouest
rapidement les unités allemandes décimé
n'était plus un obstacle pour l'armée
rouge bien supérieurs en nombre
hitler étudia donc un plan destiné à
diviser les alliés mettant en lumière
les difficultés auxquelles ils allaient
devoir faire face après guerre
[Musique]
il espérait au fond de lui-même dit
eric 1 et les britanniques des
soviétiques il était également persuadé
que les tensions entre montgomery et les
généraux américains pouvaient être
utilisé à son profit dans son désarroi
hitler imaginait que tout ce dont ils
avaient besoin était de gagner
suffisamment de temps pour produire des
armes encore plus puissante
[Musique]
des plans pour une offensive majeure
furent dressés les stratèges proposèrent
plusieurs opérations possibles à hitler
mais seulement deux étaient assez avancé
pour être considérée comme sérieuse
les deux visaient l'armée américaine car
hitler restait persuadé que l'opinion
publique américaine qui avait été assez
réticente à la volonté de roosevelt
d'entrer en guerre au tout début du
conflit allait exiger le retrait de
leurs maris et frère du théâtre
d'opérations européenne s'ils
subissaient des pertes trop lourdes ou
était battu lors d'une bataille décisive
[Musique]
le premier plan faisait appel à une
attaque sur deux fronts contre les
troupes américaines à aix avec une autre
offensive destinée à encercler les 9e et
troisième armée
elles furent jetés finalement car elle
n'avait que peu de chances de causer des
divisions dans le camp anglo américain
[Musique]
le second plomb avait une plus grande
envergure en appliquant le principe de
la guerre éclair qui avait été la
tactique victorieuse auparavant
l'objectif des allemands était de
séparer les lignes britannique des
lignes américaine et de s'emparer du
port d'anvers ceci aurait pour
conséquence de couper les
approvisionnements alliés mais également
de piéger quatre armées alliées derrière
les lignes allemandes
[Musique]
l'opération allez passer à la postérité
en tant que bataille des ardennes
en septembre 1944 la zone de l'attaqué
fut l'objet de discussions serrées et
claire insistait pour que soit choisi
les ardennes comme lieu de rassemblement
pour la bataille ses succès lors de la
bataille de france en 1940 il y avait
été spectaculaire les alliés de plus ne
s'attendait pas à une attaque allemande
dans cette région car ils étaient
concentrés sur leur avancée vers berlin
de nombreux officiers allemands étaient
opposés à cette offensive pour des
raisons variées
certains estimaient que le terrain
montagneux était trop difficile
d'autres redoutaient que si le temps
était clair l'aviation alliée soit
capable d'attaquer les forces terrestres
allemande facilement la luftwaffe
n'étant plus en mesure de réagir
le plan aurait alors peu de chances de
réussir
les officiers même en charge de
l'opération avait des doutes
[Musique]
les maréchaux walter modèle et gerd von
cunth tête pensait que l'objectif
supplémentaire de prendre le port
d'anvers était bien trop risqué
ils proposèrent une stratégie
alternative à hitler mais ce dernier
insista pour que ces plans de bataille
soit respectée cette opération devait
mobiliser 45 division et quelques unités
supplémentaires pour créer une ligne de
défense
une fois la bataille commençait la
pénurie de soldat dans l'armée allemande
souffrait ne permis d'engager que 30
division est encore en faisant appel aux
toutes dernières réserves des divisions
entières composée de vétérans et de
jeunes recrues furent formés si la
situation n'avait pas été aussi
désespérée ces hommes auraient été
réformée du service actif mais c'était
la chance ultime pour hitler de sauver
quelque chose de ces années de combat et
il n'avait d'autre choix que de tout
risquer
la diminution des réserves de carburant
allemande était un handicap sérieux qui
obligea à repousser la date de la table
du 27 novembre au 16 décembre
c'était la dernière date possible s'ils
l'attaquent devait avoir une quelconque
chance de succès
face aux américains hitler ne pouvait
plus se permettre de délais
supplémentaires
les renseignements allemands avaient
calculé que la date idéale pour une
attaque soviétique qui leur ouvrirait la
route vers berlin se situait le 20
décembre
cette opération devait donc
impérativement débuter avant cette date
hitler pariait sur le fait que staline
stopperait sont avancés pour observer la
réaction des américains devant cette
attaque éclair
il y avait longtemps que le sort n'avait
plus souri aux allemands pour cette
opération la chance allait changer de
camp
au départ le brouillard qui recouvrait
la zone de combat était une bonne
nouvelle pour les allemands car de fait
le soutien aérien des alliés devenait
impossible
les allemands étant parvenu à conserver
leurs plans secrets
l'effet de surprise allait leur donner
un avantage majeur
les américains disposent est sans
conteste des effectifs supérieurs
il était donc vital pour les allemands
afin d'avoir une chance de réussir
d'attaqué par surprise
[Musique]
depuis la tentative d'assassinât de von
stauffenberg contre hitler qui avait
failli réussir la sécurité s'était
renforcé les informations concernant
l'offensive des ardennes est a suivi et
contrôle et pour empêcher quelques
fuites que ce soit par chance pour les
allemands la résistance française ne
s'étendait pas jusqu'aux ardennes belges
ce qui signifiait que les alliés ne
pourrait pas se reposer sur des
informations locales pour comprendre ce
qui se passait de plus le trafic radio
allemand était réduit au minimum pour
remplacer les transmissions radio les
téléphones les télégraphes et les
téléscripteurs furent utilisés par les
officiers pour organiser la manoeuvre
ceci signifiait qu un des atouts majeurs
des alliés le décodeur ultras qui
généralement intercepter les
communications allemande se retrouvaient
pratiquement inutiles les allemands
appliquent est également les tactiques
similaires à celles utilisées par
eisenhower pendant la préparation
d'overlord à savoir l'organisation de
tous les mouvements de troupes de nuit
sous la protection de l'obscurité
[Musique]
cependant en dépit des efforts allemands
les alliés avaient quand même eu vent
qu'une offensive à grande échelle était
possible les alliés ne voyait pas
comment une telle action serait
envisageable de la part des allemands
pratiquement vaincu l'alertent fut
ignoré les alliés poursuivirent leurs
plans pour s'approcher de berlin en
conséquence il y eu très peu de
reconnaissance aérienne du côté allié
pratiquement les projets d'hitler ne
furent pas détecté
on
vers 5 heures du matin le 16 décembre
les troupes américaines basées dans les
ardennes furent surprise par le
bombardement intensif qui débutait
[Musique]
toutes les divisions allemandes prévues
pour se joindre à la taxe suivirent vers
8 heures la bataille faisait rage
le brouillard qui s'était répandue
pendant la nuit précédente avait
vraiment aidé les allemands en empêchant
la riposte aériennes des alliés mais les
conditions météo s'aggravant les troupes
attaquante dû ralentir le rythme
malgré l avantage de l'effet de surprise
freiné par le mauvais temps
l'avancée allemande ralentit fortement
[Musique]
tout commença à se dérouler différemment
du plan prévu les américains maintenant
au courant de l'ampleur de la tacc
reculèrent faisant sauter les ponts et
détruisant les réserves de carburant ce
qui freina davantage les allemands
[Musique]
ceux ci furieux et frustrés durcir le
traitement des américains capturés des
massacres se généralise air et hitler
donna l'ordre à ses troupes de combattre
avec la plus grande brutalité afin
d'effrayer leurs adversaires la fin de
la guerre avait beau être en vue des
milliers d'américains perdirent la vie
dans les ardennes
[Musique]
le lendemain du début de l'opération les
allemands s'emparèrent d'un dépôt de
carburant américains près de la ville de
mal bly en arrivant ils rencontrèrent un
petit groupe de soldats américains qui
après un bref combat se rendirent ces
soldats ainsi que les prisonniers faits
au dépôt de carburant furent rassemblées
dans un champ et fusillé cet acte de
barbarie gratuit et inutile entra dans
l'histoire sous le nom de massacre de
malmedy
[Musique]
classé crimes de guerre il fut jugé le
16 mai 1946 et le commandant responsable
fut condamné à mort par pendaison aux
côtés de 42 autres membres de sa
division
[Musique]
des massacres similaires à celui de
malmedy sur 20 heures dans les dernières
semaines de 1944 et eu aucun effet a
contrario pour ceux qui combattaient
dans les ardennes ils virent leur rage
d'en finir décuplée alors qu hitler
croyait les avoir terrorisé
[Musique]
une illustration en et l'encerclement
des américains dans la ville de bastogne
par la wehrmacht le général mc auliffe
commandant les troupes américaines reçu
un ultimatum de se rendre en floride
jacques propose aux expériences à ready
to help you entre autres choses ont le
sourire ce vote marque ioma nature et
surrender
mc auliffe répondit nuts des noix en
français cette réponse entra dans
l'histoire la bataille de bastogne
continuaient à faire rage
le rêve d'hitler d'un dernier baroud
victorieux s'éloigner cependant le sort
de la bataille des ardennes ne fut pas
scellé en 1944
les combats se poursuivirent après noël
et au cours de la nouvelle année les
pertes des deux côtés continuer à
s'alourdir
pourtant 1945 allait apporter la paix
dans un monde encore dans les
soubresauts de la guerre la défaite
d'hitler s'annonçait l'entente cordiale
entre roosevelt churchill et staline qui
avait permis la victoire
touchette à sa fin
[Musique]
épisode 22 l'allemagne écrasé